hey guys welcome back to another episode
of ask dr. Mike we have three special
guests joining us a and I can't wait
them to come you're doing my show yeah
hey guys welcome to another episode of
ask dr. Mike I'm here with my special
guests Arie I'm 11 years old
Daniel 14 Steven on 14 let's get it
started you mean because of all the
Instagram girls that are yeah like what
why are you trying to think that no a
lot of the girls are fine Instagram they
have a lot of these exercises that build
the back muscles know the school off and
stuff
squats leg extension so they do all
these exercises in hopes that their butt
will grow and that's it that's a thing
because you know guys find bus
attractive yeah but what I'll tell you
right now is I'm gonna spoil this for
you because I'm on Instagram and I go to
these fashion events and all that
they're either all fates the angles
photoshop angles whatever it is and the
ones that are healthiest don't look like
these crazy it's not realistic or
natural for a waist to be this tiny and
then the butt to be huge but the amount
of people that you see on Instagram with
that yo guys don't come and see if you
want to do a butt review okay so when
you're in a car your balance center of
your brain which actually happens within
an area called the semicircular canals
it's inside your ear it's kind of crazy
that your balance is within your ear one
of the fluids
yeah so the canals you have the fluids
you have the calcium that's why you see
when you spin ever yeah exactly you get
dizzy so people some people genetically
out of their control are more sensitive
to the motion when you're in a car
stopping starting all that and because
of the excess activity there they start
getting a little nauseous I don't feel
so good
[Music]
take any pants and stuff you know if you
have testicles hey why do you hate it
what's bad about we all have I mean we
all have the guys have them yeah it's I
think it's unnecessary like if there's a
problem there go to specialists you got
yourself in a little trouble with me on
that because she said go see a
specialist why do you need to see a
specialist why can't you come see me as
the family med no I'm saying I know I
know you don't like that because you
think she always goes to that they know
your history and stuff yeah there's no
need to you know meet lurking down there
I used to think the same way you're
thinking now and then as I was in med
school I started seeing patients and I
would ask them like you know anything
wrong down there and they would say no
and then I would check and something bad
would be going on there and they may
have been uncomfortable to tell you and
that happens all the time Dan it's crazy
but it happens the harm of looking at it
making someone feel uncomfortable is
outweighed by the benefit of like if we
could save them and find something and
give them the treatment so they don't to
deal with that you know meeting new
people and being and I guess like a
healthy relationship and socially like
we're like intimate with someone what
we've seen is that people who are
married and long-term and are in good
relationships they have better health
outcomes it doesn't mean that you have
to get married in order to get those
benefits but it's just something that
we've seen after looking periods of time
and giving people surveys if I was to
tell someone should you be in a
relationship the question would be a do
they want to be in a relationship be are
they happy in that relationship and only
from there I can give them some sort of
advice that being said humans are social
creatures we like hanging out together
in fact if you keep any animal or human
in isolation for too long we go crazy
why do you think in jail one of the
worst punishments of solitary
confinement what's your favorite thing
isn't it hanging out with your friends
Yeah right who's like hanging out their
friends you don't like hanging out
new idea friends are gonna see this all
right Tommy I don't have any eyes like
three maybe okay yeah that's a lot of
friends you don't have to have a million
friends if you have three really cool I
like a lot of friends but I don't know
again it's just all about trust I've
actually had an issue with my neck you
can you could diagnose it
no you can't diagnose on camera but I
don't want to get off this trust thing
yeah you know I just want to make a
comment on it well it's big time you did
it you sure thanks
thank you I trusted okay no one can make
you feel happy or sad only you can make
yourself feel happy or sad do you agree
with that kind of because other people
could have an impact on you how tell me
like bullying okay bullying let's say
someone says something mean to you oh
that green shirt is ugly now who decides
if that upsets them do you see where I'm
going with it though all right now can
close my eyes and think one really bad
thought about you and one really good
thought about you if my eyes are closing
I don't say it out loud will it change
how you feel right now probably not
probably not or not you know how if your
like arm gets chopped off it doesn't
heal heal when your arm gets chopped off
why does anyway if you put the arm back
and reattach
I give you put plates and screws yeah
just like why are you touching a finger
uh I don't get all this video came to
trusting too big but then keep putting
armies always like that's because
[Music]
any guesses what a heart attack is like
why does it happen I don't know I'm just
gonna think like somebody scares you but
I feel like it's not really that funny
because you like that no there's some
truth behind getting a heart check B so
please sure if you have a lot of plaque
they say a lot of plaque is like the
size of a grain of ass and and if it
starts building up that means blood flow
is constricted and then if it breaks off
that plaque and that always love cells
like start going on to it and such
clotting you're on the right track so
you're really close the heart supplies
blood to the rest of your body but it
also it needs blood for itself
it's a muscle right so the heart has
very little blood vessels like the
little tunnels that deliver the blood
also that go to the heart those little
tunnels but those tunnels are much
smaller than the big ones that deliver
blood everywhere else so they're more
susceptible to getting blocked off with
plaque plaque is what happens when you
eat unhealthy when you don't exercise
it's basically these fatty waxy
substances that build up on the walls of
the tunnel that continuously get bigger
and then can block off the blood flow go
into your heart and if your heart
doesn't get enough blood there's a heart
attack a heart attack is literally your
heart being in pain because part of it
is dying so does that make sense about
how heart attacks work yeah for sure cuz
I go out it's tunnels it's like plumbing
it's like no you have like a busted
busted busted plug alright guys thanks
for watching our video if you want more
content with these crazy lunatics drop
it down below in the comments
smash that like and subscribe button
with the notification what no he told me
not to ask that but I want to ask it
anyway so as always stay happy and
healthy I stole your lies stay yeah you
say happy Heat no sorry and yes I'm
gonna say as always
okay happy don't mind oh yeah okay are
you ready
Oh Mac as always stay happy and healthy